[Music]
the brain's ability to imagine is a
fascinating mystery i grew up in mexico
and my small family crossed the border
because we imagined a better life in the
united states
later i escaped an abusive home because
i imagined a better future for myself
and much later my imagination inspired
me to dream of having a job where i
could ponder the largest questions of
life i'm fernanda de la torre and at the
mcgowan institute i use math to study
how our brain understands the difference
between imagination and reality let me
give you an example follow the motion of
the spin cube do you imagine it dropping
onto the purple surface or sliding down
a ramp
it's hard to tell right
that's because the visual clues are
vague and the movement of the pink cube
could be caused by different physical
realities
now what if i pair the same video with a
sound clue
now it's obvious the cube is clearly
sliding down the ramp that's because
your brain combined the visual clues and
the sound clues to determine what was
really happening with the cube
i used artificial neural networks or a
series of math equations to understand
how the brain makes these important
mental calculations so that we can
distinguish imagination from reality